hey everybody welcome back to townscaper
i have no idea why the last video i made
on this game has so many views but
huge thanks to the youtube algorithm i
guess and my apologies to everybody who
heard the discord notifications
it was kind of a quick video i just put
out about a game that i wasn't really
expecting too much
from i mean i wasn't expecting much from
the video i was expecting quite a lot
from the game because it's off to a
really great start and i do like it a
lot
um but yeah i accidentally pranked
hundreds of thousands of people
sorry not sorry um i kind of like the
fact that
i i i pranked people accidentally i
suppose
anyway uh to move into what this video
is actually about and you're probably
looking at this going this isn't
venice this isn't what you promised in
the title and thumbnail of this video
there's just one more thing that i
quickly want to show before we actually
get into it
i want to keep releasing videos on this
game every now and then because the
creator is still updating it as well and
adding lots of
cool small features and bug fixes to it
so that's really nice to see and
something that got added on the 5th of
august
is a very small change that can actually
allow for a bunch of creative stuff
and it's garden paths as you may know
you get gardens in between buildings
and something new that was added is once
you have
enough of these kind of arches these
connecting
pieces uh in the middle of gardens you
can get some garden parts and it's
pretty neat and sometimes you can even
get
a little fountain like this at a certain
junction
so you know it's not too special but
just like everything in this game
because it you know uses this very
procedural generation
it still allows for a lot of variety in
what you do with your buildings
i'm not even entirely sure what else you
can do with these paths but it's cool to
see how
for instance if i do this and then do
this it's just
cool to see a change and see what
happens to
all of the parts here anyway let's get
into the video
and start the time lapse and start
building some venice
alright now i've seen my fair share of
youtube videos of townscaper at this
point and it seems like a general trend
is for people to start off with the
foundations of their city just
laying out what it's going to look like
and what the shape is going to be before
they actually start adding buildings
and i'm going to do the same here mostly
because i
want to shape the grand canal first
which is the
the main canal that goes through the
middle of the city
and this canal has a very distinct s
shape
if you look from above and because this
is townscaper
and this recreation is of course not
going to be super accurate
i wanted to make sure that i got the
shape of the grunt canal
kind of realistically down so that at
least
it would look somewhat like venice
looking from above
and i also wanted the size of the canal
to be as smooth as possible and to sort
of follow the curves of the naturally
generated grid
so that just took a bit of try and error
to find that space
but i think with the layout that i got
going now it's decent
and i can still also feature the island
here in the in the south
and besides that the only real realism
i suppose of trying to make this look
like venice is
that i'm trying to also imitate the
urban fabric that venice has
i'm not really going to recreate any of
the the spaces in the city because that
would be insanely difficult and
really pretty much impossible with uh
townscaper at least as it is right now
the only exception to that i guess would
be
saint mark's square which i'm trying to
figure out how to do right now
uh the big red tower you see is the the
bell tower
of the basilica which of course also
doesn't look super accurate but i think
it it gets the idea across
like this is this is clearly uh the
square which is
which it is supposed to be and then here
is the doses palace
and um the basilica itself i
i couldn't really figure out how to fit
that into the picture anymore so at this
point i'm not actually adding that
also in real life the tower should
actually be detached from the building
but because this is townscaper and the
space is very limited i figured it would
look slightly better
with the tower just attached to the
building like that
and something you'll also see is that
all of the buildings around this square
have lots of arches
so i'm just using the in-game archways
to try and recreate that a little bit
but i think where it gets really
interesting is in making the urban
fabric
of the city itself this is not actually
my first time
trying to make venice in townscaper but
the first time i just wasn't really
happy with it because i took a very
similar approach to
building the buildings that i already
had done before
and it looked very similar to my first
video of the game
and it just didn't really look like the
urban fabric that you see in venice
i have to add i've never actually been
there but i have
google earth it's a lot if that's a word
so
i just didn't really get the same kind
of vibes venice is very dense
and has lots of buildings in very tight
spaces with
not a lot of street between it and
definitely not a lot of open spaces
between the buildings either
and my first attempt just created very
small houses with lots of streets and
lots of space between it and it just
didn't really resemble the urban fabric
of venice from above so
on this attempt i am trying to fill the
map with as much building
as i can realistically get away with
while also
trying to fit a few canals and small
streets in between
so a lot of this is actually down to try
and figure out
what kind of tricks i can i can pull on
the game
to put lots of building pieces together
while maintaining the red roofs and
trying to prevent those those flat roofs
from forming
and i think a major part of the trick is
just that
if you have lots of building pieces
together
um and you don't have any odd shapes
sticking out
and um whenever many buildings are
connecting in certain places you you
have some height variation so that
different roofs can form as long as you
kind of work out the rules
of how buildings form in this way you
can actually connect
many buildings together and fill up a
huge percentage of the map with
just buildings instead of streets or
water
um so most of the time you'll see me
place
two by one grid buildings together which
form these nice rows
of buildings where you can see the uh
the gable is on the side of the building
and then the entire row just ends up
working like a row house
very similar to what buildings look like
in the game if you only make them one
square wide
except these are all too square wide but
even when you build buildings like this
you can still add a row of building
behind the whole thing and it'll still
have a regular roof
or you can connect buildings in
all directions and as long as you get
the shapes right they'll all still have
normal roofs
so as you can see it's shaping up to be
super dense
and you get these lots of little streets
i think the only downside
to building like this where you just
connect many building pieces
is the fact that everything seems to be
a lot smaller
the scale of the game seems to be a lot
smaller because whereas
if you just build buildings that are
single grid spaces
large you can very quickly create
something that looks like a huge city
with lots of town houses
but this scale while i think it's a bit
more realistic
and results in a slightly better looking
urban fabric
you can tell that the map is quite small
because uh with the entire layout that
i've created here
i am almost using all of the map and
it just looks twice as small than uh
or as the the one that i built on the
first episode just because the buildings
are much bigger
but in the end i'm pretty happy with it
and
i think it works out this way so i'm
definitely gonna keep it like this
i'm also not going to have too much
variation in the colors of the buildings
i know that of course in townscaper you
can add all these different varieties of
colors
but realistically most of venice
consists of very beige
white light-ish colors for the walls and
then all the red roofs
so the roof part is down pretty much
perfectly
but yeah that aside i'm keeping it
pretty simple and not really adding too
much variety there
and something i should also note while
i'm at it and also
my apologies to all the italians out
there but
i am building a few more buildings that
exist in real life or at least
townscaper variants that are inspired by
it
so the building that i just built on the
lower right on this island
is the basilica of santa maria de la
salute whatever that is
i've never actually been there but it
looks really cool looks like a beautiful
building
and i definitely butchered it in
townscaper but it looks like um
it is one of those signature buildings
of the city and especially as it sits
close to the water there
that at least i wanted something that
kind of resembled it
to add a bit of variety to the city and
not just all make it
houses but that aside yeah it's pretty
much just houses
one thing that i did figure out actually
works out a lot better than trying to
plan canals beforehand
is to just build streets and
after you've built all the streets try
and figure out if there are any streets
that you want to or
can turn into canals as opposed to
placing canals down first also i'm
working on a giant church here
which is inspired by uh a real life
church as well
it's um i forgot the name actually gosh
what's it called again
oh yeah it's the the basilica the
ferrari something like that which is a
really big church in venice but yeah
i just on my first try of making venice
i i first
laid out where i wanted all of the
canals to go but that turned out to be
quite a challenge because trying to
figure out where the buildings would go
along that and trying to see how the
street pattern would look
turned out to be kind of difficult and
in hindsight
if you want to build a city with canals
in townscape i honestly think it's a lot
easier to just
build it without canals just build
streets at first and then see which
streets you can turn into canals
because you'll always have these
perfectly spaced out
urban fabrics with places that can be
turned into canals
the only downside is of course that you
won't have any
canals with roads next to it but you can
always clear out some buildings if you
want to have a strip with roads as well
i just found it interesting that
sometimes it was
easier to add a canal in hindsight as
opposed to
planning it out at first and trying to
figure out you know how the buildings
could fit around it
obviously i did plan a few canals here
but
it is a it is a decent way to try and do
them in hindsight honestly
and at the end here i'm just trying to
fill out the remaining space of the map
that i still have left
but that is pretty much it not much else
to do here
and it's basically finished so let's
take a look at how it turned out
so here's the final result and if i turn
on the grid you can see that i almost
used the entire grid
it still looks a little bit small
compared to many townscaper
videos that i've seen but yeah it's it's
really the bigger buildings
speaking of which i do kind of want to
explain them again because i am
very aware that i explained them
terribly the first time around without
an example to show so
let me just look at these buildings
something that i did for most of the map
was to build buildings that are two grid
spaces deep and one grid space wide
so this row for instance is three
buildings like that
each a different color so that you can
get a different colored roof and they
all look like individual buildings
very neat and then you can still add a
ring of
lower building around that as well and
you'll just have very nice roof
so with these kinds of tricks you can
fill
most of the map in with building spaces
and with roof space
which i think for venice being as dense
as city as it
is was really essential to getting the
look right
and that's about as much as you can do
this church isn't really realistic
but it was a small attempt at trying to
create some flying buttresses or at
least
kind of emulate the look of them and
um i'm not entirely sure why i put
this like this on the front there must
be oh yeah there you go
that's there just to make sure that the
whole thing is roof so
yeah even though you might not be able
to tell right away there are many
buildings on this map which
have some strange shapes or roof pieces
sticking out just to make sure that
everything is a red tiled roof
and then of course there's the plaza
itself which in real life
should actually be closed off as well
but i think in the game
it works pretty alright like this it
also showcases how cool
this uh this thing is that you get when
some buildings are very close to each
other and their floors are
tall enough you get these well i guess
they're clothes actually
i'm not sure if they're clothes or just
drapes or
flags for celebrations but it looks
pretty cool anyway
and of course there's a tower itself as
well which is
trying to emulate the real look i'm not
sure how much it looks like venice
from the side but at least from above
it does seem to give a very venetian
vibes so
i'm pretty happy with that and then
there's also this canal which i think
this was one that i
created afterwards this used to be a
street and then i turned it into a canal
and honestly i think this is the one
that works out the best
of the variety of canals that i have in
the city especially with this kind of
door connecting to the other side and
this
well this sort of gate that the canal is
going through i think that's pretty cool
there's also one here which is very
straight and straightforward
there's one here which kind of cuts
through the middle of the city and
comes back in here and
well there's here one two and there's
one here as well so
there are quite a few canals actually a
bit more i feel like
than you would expect at first glance
but there's still not too much it's very
difficult to fit in as many canals as
you would have in real life venice
anyway i feel like i at least want to
showcase
my quote-unquote failed attempt at
venice so
just for a second i'm gonna look at that
monstrosity and
explain why i didn't like it as much
yeah i already can't stand to look at
this mess
but a small analysis of what went wrong
here i think
is mostly just the fact that all of
these houses are tiny and they're all
connected
in ways that aren't particularly like
the urban fabric of venice
and what's what's up with this actually
why is all of this stone
that doesn't okay well
i mean this is this is always a
challenge isn't it i guess that works
but yeah it's uh it just doesn't work as
well i also think the colors
are a bit too off and all together this
is the kind of thing that you can make
in townscape and it still looks super
cool because the the art style of the
game is really nice but it doesn't
really have the same
feeling of the harmonious urban fabric
is
as venice so it just doesn't work out as
much and it just
turns more into a blur of tiny houses
still looks pretty cool but that's
mostly courtesy of the game
and i'm not too proud of myself for this
one
so what did we learn today i don't know
but i had fun building this so that was
pretty cool and yeah
thanks for watching and i hope to see
you guys in
the next townscaper video when that ever
happens
take care